this next story is both really funny and
also really tragic because lots of
people
get their so-called news from sean
hannity on fox news
last night on his program sean hannity
sort of haphazardly and indirectly
admitted that he doesn't vet
the information that he gives out on the
show now he was trying to make the case
that he's so independent that he doesn't
check with other people he doesn't
need anybody's permission to say
whatever the hell he wants on his
program nobody
is telling him what stories to cover and
not to cover but what he actually ended
up admitting is that he doesn't even
necessarily know whether what he's
telling you is accurate he doesn't
necessarily know
if what he's telling you is true which
is actually
not unique to sean hannity's program as
far as fox opinion programs are
concerned
but i'm going to get back to that and it
relates to a lawsuit involving tucker
carlson from a few months ago
but let's set it up here is a clip of a
defiant and principled sean hannity
telling you
he might be giving you false information
regularly
on his program take a look we in this
hour
i am not told what to say i don't vet
the information on this program that i
give out
we have always been independent follow
our own path on this show
that's not going to change for me ever
if you thought
that it might change this will not
change
ever says sean hannity now
of course anybody who understands and
pays attention to fox news with a
critical eye
knows this i mean just in the past few
months sean hannity notably promoted
bogus coronavirus treatments and cures
he promoted and regularly promotes voter
fraud conspiracy theories related to the
election including that donald trump won
this state that state the other state
none of which
there's a speck of evidence for but the
problem
is that lots of uh hannity's viewers
don't realize that this is merely an
opinion show
and one we've now learned thanks to sean
hannity admitting it
it's one where hannity doesn't even vet
the things that he puts out on the air
but here's what i want to remind you
this is really the important thing in an
effort to sort of build an understanding
of media literacy
this is not actually unique to hannity
this is not
about sean hannity per se back in
september we covered this on the bonus
show
fox news's own lawyers said in court
that the audience shouldn't believe
that what tucker carlson says on his
program is facts
there was a case against tucker carlson
for slander
in the southern district of new york and
in the opinion from the judge
there were quotes from fox news's
lawyers made
in the case and the defense that fox
news lawyers put forward
was that anyone who watches tucker
carlson's show
should just be able to tell from what
they referred to as the general tenor of
the program
that tucker carlson is not quote stating
actual facts
on his program and that what tucker
carlson is doing this
is lawyers for fox news saying tucker
should not be held to that standard
because tucker uses exaggeration
and non-literal commentary this is the
evil genius
of this you have an entire political
movement in this country
that has been taught molded and
conditioned
to take their political agenda from fox
news
if fox news says cancel culture is the
issue then that's the issue and you
spread it around if fox news says the
issue is
you know trump really won or whatever
that that becomes the issue and in
particular
they get this agenda from the nighttime
opinion shows on fox news
of which you know we're including uh
sean hannity tucker carlson laura ingram
janine pirro on the weekends
um you know lou dobbs i think is fox
business uh
mark levin all of these people we all
know
that these are merely bogus opinion
shows that are meant to fire up and
radicalize and anger the base which
works
and then you see fox news successfully
set the agenda
that pervades politics around the
country for the american right wing
but when the rubber hits the road and
these hosts start getting sued for
slander or they have other
legal issues because of false statements
they've made the lawyers show up and
they don't even hesitate they
immediately go to anybody should be able
to tell these are not facts being
presented
this is entertainment it's non-literal
commentary and it's
it's actually what alex jones's lawyers
also argued
in i don't remember if it was a some
kind of libel or slander
suit or maybe his divorce proceedings i
don't even remember
but his lawyers essentially said you you
can't you can't litigate anything that's
said on the show because it's and it's
entertainment it's just a character
that alex jones is playing that's
exactly the problem though which is that
fox news's business model has been let's
dress up radical conspiracies and wild
speculation
that would not normally be on national
cable tv
but let's produce it in a way that it
looks like real news
and when you flip around and importantly
fox news
on the cable dial often is right next to
actual news networks
people flip around and they see it and
it's like you know
looks like news the anchors talk like
this is news
i guess this is news and people fall for
it so
where they say in the lawsuit defending
in the defense against the lawsuit
against tucker carlson when the fox news
lawyers say
any viewer should be able to tell this
is not
factual news where we present facts
that's true
but their very business model has
depended on
looking like real news so that when
people see it they think they're
watching news
part of it is a media literacy issue
it's an education issue for sure
but part of the problem is that fox news
is participating
in being deliberately confusing about
exactly what they are putting out they
blend
the news and opinion we've talked about
that before
but they also present opinion shows
as if they are serious programs rather
than mere
entertainment and what it leads to is an
audience that when they don't get what
they want on fox
they end up being radicalized over to
networks like newsmax and oan
and that's exactly what i want to talk
about next when you see me sitting here
at the microphone
oftentimes i'm wearing a shirt by a
company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i asked teddy stratford to
be a sponsor of the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down and
spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things
really do a lot to make a big difference
when you're looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout